[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon joueur mais petit ami j'espère que
vous êtes tous de bonne humeur ce soir
plus d'un mois pas trop
bravo c'est ce qu'il faut avoir toujours
le sourire et ne jamais boudé comme
nounours je suis toujours content même
quand nicolas et pimprenelle me faut des
niches non les chats bonsoir les enfants
oui ya main
oui c'est une belle chanson 2-3 sa toile
à chamant seignosse vous prenez une
annonce si bien les saignements ses
frais autre cible chameau
perdue dans le désert minima en sus la
mort qui nettoie toit doit doit toi moi
loin loin loin il ya divine la preuve
finances en arrêt j'ai sauf un dodo dodo
des taux de doute c'est bien le
président de la bonté de dieu
himalaya jacques arino
[Musique]
allez allez allez allez
il sait faire la révérence et les mages
noon ou nounou bouge les cailloux que
toulouse où sont nos colonnes c'est là
en aussi léger canadien d'antan qui
passionna tendancieux fermer les yeux
ouverts tessa plein de désert il sous la
main les flancs
ah l'amour
himalaya jambes à calcutta cindy marina
un himalaya java calcutta sidi barils
allez allez allez allez allez allez à
pomper pomper et myriam en off et bien
le chameau nounours il est fatigué il va
au lit lui aussi ne vous en avez de la
chance
la g et al ahly leur bonne nuit les
petits
beaune une annonce à demain elle était
très jolie cette chanson bravo très joli
mais un peu fatigante jeux dos et soif
pas trop patience nounours fait comme
les chameaux je ne suis pas un chameau
je suis un loup l'ours en route nounours
va lui les enfants fait pour 1
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
soir les enfants
bon froid
patron je descend vite chez mes petits
amis
je vais leur montrer mon livre dit marc
niakhar nonos mon et shan leurs propos
papaux
[Musique]
bonsoir les petits mais oui
voulez-vous que je vous raconte une
histoire quelle histoire
ça te corrige au delà d'un mec à caser
ses aînés oui les drôles
voilà cornichons paix dans la forêt là
sur la plage au bord de la mer
il s'est perdu que je suis beau mais oui
notre petite amie s'est perdu son papa
et sa maman
le cherche partout avec dada avec dada
bien sûr et il rencontre un vieux
vitrier qui pousse une charrette bien
lourde cornichons qui est rageante y
aident le vieux vitrier a poussé sa
charrette
il arrive dans la grande ville où il ya
de grandes maisons et le vieux vitrier
gris nez et cornichons griot syfy
j ai pas voilà la grande dame beurre au
seul allah ne viennent pas moi non plus
je voudrais un verre oraux pour
remplacer celui que j'ai cassé une autre
petite amie lui découpe à pau vers visa
car elle qui met à la place de celui qui
ment et tout le monde dans la rue rit on
la montrant du doigt et la dame qui
s'est regardé dans une glace se met très
fort en colère mais le vieux vitrier ne
se fâche pas il sait bien que notre
petit corniche on est un peu dans la
lune et pour le remercier de l'avoir
aidé il lui offre une merveilleuse
grosses bouteilles en verre de venise
laquelle il met les terres qu'elle agira
lui a donné mais oui allons les enfants
l'histoire est finie nous allons nous
coucher patrick nossent voilà ce qu'ils
sont gentils
nous sommes une famille bonne nuit les
petits la jette à la ligne 1
ado
[Musique]
alors les enfants
l'histoire vous a plu oui
eh bien allez vite vous coucher on n'y
va pas trop en route mon cher nounours
bah des nuits fait de pur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants bon froid patron
raconter leur la suite des aventures du
petit cornichons moi je descends leur
montrer le dakar de nous rouler seul
bobo propos cornichons et le gros du
front sont devenus inséparables notre
petit ami ed de son mieux le bûcheron
tué près nounours je suis prêt pas trop
vous pouvez raconter à vos patrons
à présent c'est l'automne tuquoi
l'automne annonce l'automne vient plus
tu du côlon oui et c'est un autre date
que les fans aient tout bizarre mais oui
les feuilles tombent
et pourtant la forêt n'a jamais été
aussi belle
les arbres sont de toutes les couleurs
et notre petit ami corniche on s'amuse à
faire de gros tas de feuilles mortes
il ramasse des pommes de pin il joue
aussi avec juliette à son hibou il lance
en l'air une pomme de pain que judy
l'état rattrape comme une balle à l'écho
qui cette juliette à le bûcheron un peu
plus loin si des grosses branches camp
du ch ont que dans quelques bons
champignons pour le dîner le petit
garçon ramassent quelques cailloux bien
rond qu'ils déposent à terre dans son
mouchoir le nom des champignons
cornichons lui crie le bûcheron et notre
petit ami ramasse encore quelques
cailloux bien rond au à l'encan nichons
il est l'heure d'aller dîner dit le
bûcheron qui s'arrêtent de travailler et
cornichons emporte son mouchoir plein de
cailloux mais julietta qui sait bien que
son petit ami est un peu dans la lune
cueille vite un énorme champignon brin
tout rond oh le beau simple guy le
bûcheron quand elle le pose sur la table
dans leur cabane en bois
le bûcheron le fait cuire dans la
cheminée sur la braise et ensuite tous
les trois ils se régalent nie pas ce que
ça a l'air bon dès qu'ils ont fini de
dîner ils vont sagement se coucher
évidemment
et notre petit ami s'endort bien vite en
pensant à sa maman à son papa et à son
cheval data tandis que juliette à faye
fidèlement sur lui
allons les enfants l'histoire est finie
nous allons nous coucher tout de suite
merci voilà ce qu'ils sont gentils mais
amoché manu de nuit bonne nuit les
petits la j'éteins la lumière
adobe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors les enfants
l'histoire vous a plu oui eh bien allez
vite vous coucher
on y va pas trop en route mon cher de
l'ours dans les nuits fait pauvre
[Musique]
au revoir les enfants
je ne vous demande pas si vous êtes
sages je suis sûr que voulaient au rouge
patron tous les enfants sont sages et
toi nounours moi voulons patron vous le
savez je suis un nounours exemplaires je
descends voir mais petit ami olé schell
et la pomme papotin 1,4 alors jamais bat
4 as toi nicolas
j'arrive le moci jour au le joli jeu de
dominos et le procos tu t'es pas vos
comme ça toi non
mais d'où viennent ces jolies de
l'humour il veut c'est maman qui les a
achetées
on est sorti avec elle elle nous sommes
nés dans des gros magasin ce que ceux de
boue on a eu des choses il y avait des
escaliers qui montent est tout seul tu
te rends compte des escaliers roulants
ces pratiques oui mais pas nicolas weber
on a pris les escaliers et on a marché
tout l'après midi on a fait cet âge on
est allé voir les joueuses qui ont
achevé et nicolas voulait pu rentrer à
la maison et maman elle a dit qu'elle
nous emmènerait plus puis on est rentré
et moment et s'est couché
il avait mal à la tête la pauvre ce
qu'elle doit être fatigué allons les
petits allez vite vous couchez vous
aussi mais pour nicolas
il faut mettre ton pyjama j'ai dit non
non et non
d'accord je vais au lit mais je garde
mon beau costume ne fait pas le bébé
nicolas tué un homme à la caisse et
nicolas ballon mais petit patronale au
dodo 6 et 9
mais j'ai pas sommeil quand on va dans
des grands magasins
on est toujours fatigué ah voilà nicolas
nicolas
d ici petit garnement que à 8 on pige à
ma sur ton costume up et cette cravate
je vais me fâcher
ben non
mais pas ponelle où est elle passée
décidément vous faites les petits
diables
eh bien nous ne viendrons pas vous voir
demain ça y est je suis gaucher nounours
moi aussi why a quand même vous n'êtes
pas haute
vous m'avez mis en colère je ne sais pas
si je viendrai d'hommes un ballon en or
mais vos buts et la jeter la lumière la
nuit de noces à demain adoma petit
coquin bonne nuit les enfants ne fait
surtout pas comme nicolas et pimprenelle
allez vous coucher sans faire de caprice
embrasser bien fort vos parents et
faites de beaux rêves en a trop j'ai eu
chaud en route mon bon nours pas de nuit
adobe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants savez vous ce que
notre nounours a fait aujourd'hui il est
allé dans la forêt tout seul au patro
que l' aventure jeu des seront vite la
raconter à nicolas il n'y a pas trop
belle
olé schell plus pop hip hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop bonsoir les enfants où son
tube oh vous m'avez fait peur ce n'est
pas le jour
si vous saviez tout ce qui m'est arrivé
aujourd'hui dites nous si vous saviez
si vous aviez ans je passais par le bois
le coucou chante et dans son joli chant
faisait beaucoup et moi je croyais qu'il
n'y êtes co pluie de coups compile tous
et moi du conjoint sauvé son vin et moi
du coup je mens sauveur
[Musique]
quand je passais par le pré le faucheur
prochain dans son joli j'en faisais à
quelle chaleur auquel chaleur et moi je
croyais qu'il disait à quel voleur
auquel voleurs et moi du coup je manceau
veut sombre et moi du coup je pense au
vert quand je passais près de l'étang
canard allait chantons et dansons joli
show faisait
et moi je croyais qu'une disait qu'il
aille au point qu'il aille au point et
moi du logement sauve sombre et moi du
coup j'ai mon sauveur où sont ils passés
chez ninon bonne nuit avant de jouer
bonne nuit les petits paul depuydt petit
canard nino sera vite là j'ai pas la
lumière
bonne nuit nicolas pourrait aborder
[Musique]
partons sans faire de bruit nounours
tout notre petit monde dort déjà oui pas
trop ce que je les aime dans nuit des
enfants fait de bourrage soir les
enfants
j'espère que nicolas et pimprenelle ont
été sages aujourd'hui qu'en penses-tu
nounours bien sûr qu'ils ont te sache
pas trop je descends tout de suite les
voir mon échelle hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop au bon d'accord nicolas j en
fais tes bras et moi je vais m'habiller
comme les dames qui sont dans les
journaux de maman bon dépêche toi car je
suis prêt bon soit au pardon je me
trompe je suis chez à photographe qui
trompe banos en soit tu es chez le grand
photographe nicolas et tu tombes bien tu
va m'aider oui monsieur nicolas je vais
être votre assistant nous allons
photographier mademoiselle à des moyens
copine quand mademoiselle catherine gars
ne bougeait plus regardée via un petit
oiseau qui va sortir
coucou c'est moi le petit oiseau toi tu
tiens cette branche
comme s'il y avait un arbre à côté
d'elle oui monsieur
voilà
oh ben ça très bien n'a bougé plus c'est
un salaire mais si bien le seul
s'attaquera pas pr neil je ne t'avais
pas reconnu mais khartoum ne bouge pas
reste comme ça tu es très bien fait une
photo je suis photogénie séparés et
voici il a dit fleurs toit neuf tu tiens
ça tomberait comme ça parfait vous êtes
très mots je souris super ça y est ouf
il est lourd ce parapluie c'est une
ombrelle ne nous vous êtes prêts voilà
la nikon gueule
super ses pairs c'est bon sens
je pose le petit oiseau et voilà la
d1000 fleurs au salon à temps complet
toutes les fleurs de la maison n'ont pas
tous du cola on peut je vais voir et
site occupé toute la flore que je plante
ailleurs et nous nous non je crois qu'il
vaut mieux que j'aille me coucher je
mettais sur m a chip tous mes fleurs
pour faire ça ça le dépôt de fleurs la
vie comme je te donnerai tout est vrai
vous n'allez pas vous disputez vous avez
fait de très jolies photos
et puis tu sais bien très photographique
aulas au long en dormez-vous vie la
jettent à laleu
bono n'est pas l'onu et manon paniez
nicolas bonne nuit
l'adie pots de fleurs bonne nuit les
enfants
il ne faut jamais se disputer c'est très
vilain oui cette trêve il
allez vite vous coucher et fait beau
rêve
[Musique]
smart nos amis beauce fois aujourd'hui
c'est pain que ce porche pas que nous
sommes tous contents lol lol lol lol
alors nous avons rencontré des clash
dans le ciel elles nous ont donné ce bel
oeuf de pâques pour nicolas et
pimprenelle la vie de leur partenaire ou
l'échelle supporte pas que nous sommes
tous contents holl holl holl holl holl
holl holl j'étais gay qu'est ce que tu
nous apportes c'était ne nous avons vu
les années 70 où ils nous l'ont confié
pour qu'on vous le taux n'est tenu qu'il
allait j'ai rêvé d'un posez le sur la
table et ouvre le je crois bien qu'il
contient quelques shows aux jo et
l'offrir
voilà at once ou non qui les mini
ateliers bien sûr il sort de son offre
oui dois voir ça moi je vais lui
chercher des graines
[Musique]
tiens pousseur où il a soit venu nous
chercher de l'eau petit pouce aux tiens
j'allais poussins webdo manon ce qu'est
ce qu'on va en faire
oui il saurait mieux à la campagne est
dans merde ne nous amener à la campagne
non non tu veux trouvera une maman
points excellente idée les enfants il
sera beaucoup plus heureux avec une
maman poule allons petit poussin on
retourne dans ton nom et s'est vite au
dos tu vois nous aussi on va se coucher
moussa on irait tout voir à la campagne
et soit bien sage alors poussons tué
près août
depuis les petits d'hommes
là j'ai pas la lumière connais tu
apprenais tobia nicolas connu des
enfants
allez vous coucher vite vite nous aussi
patron partons vite vite
nous devons ramener le petit poussin
chez sa maman est bien en route nounours
bonne nuit fêtes de beaurains voir mes
petits amis
mais qui est ce qui pleure c'est
sûrement un pb capricieux pas trop en
tout cas ces villes je crois que c'est
poopy la poupée de pas preneur si c'est
elle qui n'a grande rade un nappage
l'agro dreux
pas très moral au plus haut
et voilà si 90 des déchets il pourra pas
j'ai mis de côté tous les âges et tous
les rois bonsoir je viens gros des le
bébé qui fera qu'après sens où es-tu le
cpie pas bonne elle lui fait sa toilette
dans la salle de bain à lui long mapipis
finit là là que gros chagrin en voilà
des façons de crier quand on vous fait
sa toilette ok t'es toi quand nico tu
ferais bien que la finul père et elle va
s'endormir bien sache mais bon si c'est
comme ça je vais jouer aux cartes avec
nicolas c'est ça il ne fait pas de bruit
pendant que jean dorna poopy chéri
[Musique]
ma poupée chéri ne veut pas dormir petit
enjeu mien tu me fait souffrir fermeté
12 yeux tes yeux de saphir d'or poopy
dourdan
où je vais sévir
il faudrait je crois pour te rendre
visage à mantoue de soi de riches comme
ça tu voudrais des rouges à ton clair
des cas des bijoux d'or fin et mille
autres choses
mapou péché
ne veut pas dormir petit ange bien tu me
fait souffrir ferme t12 yeux des yeux de
sa fille dort poopy noces d'or
où je vais sévir
[Musique]
j'ai lu que j'avais avec moi les
collants s'allier au lieu de faire un
bruit pareil tu va réveiller ma poupée
là on a plus joué
enfin c'est complet quel melon silence
médaille à 4 à chaque fois mois toujours
est la poupée avec pas première moto
râleurs mal à aller on est vous disputez
plus c'est fini il faut dormir ne manie
pas de nuit les enfants là j'éteins la
lumière
[Musique]
bonne nuit poppy à nicolas monneau
dormez bien
[Musique]
apprenez la raison il est l'heure de
dormir les enfants à te voilà mauvais
joueur me patron semi colloque ces
nounours qui n'est pas un bon joueur il
faut savoir perdre en gardant le sourire
je vais seul patron allons en route
nounours bonne nuit des enfants
et lorsque vous jouez avec vos amis ne
fait surtout pas comme nounours et
nicolas ne vous chamailler pas je ne le
ferai plus patron
bonne nuit bonsoir des enfants bonsoir
bonsoir je connais un nouveau jeu ce
qu'on va s'amuser je peux y aller
patron bien sûr nounours tu es tellement
pressé d'aller jouer à l'on amuse toi
bien mais ne triche pas soyez tranquille
bon le cheval voie lente un cigare de
s'amuser
bonsoir mes amis ce soir mes enfants
nous jouons ensemble
colin maillard d'accord c'est très
facile un joueur se met sur les yeux un
tissu sain et fait donc ils le voient
plus rien et ils vont attraper l'un des
autres joueurs et le reconnaître on le
touche en voilà jaubert ce foulard sur
mes yeux comme ça là
je ne vois plus rien et maintenant je
vais essayer de saisir l'un d'eux vous
[Applaudissements]
ne pourrez pas si vite c'est pas facile
voilà j'en l'ua c'est nicolas j'ai gagné
j'ai reconnu du collagène en cinq mois
maintenant
oui tiens je te mêles foulard ce que je
joue bien quand même
ce que je suis fort au président non
transparents envoient là on voit tout à
travers ses vraies et colin batch rogge
a pas preneur
tu as triché tv vous vous croyez si
annonce va jouer à colin maillard otomo
on va encore frapper colin maillard
pêche toi voilà cherchons maintenant il
fait tout noir là dessous
[Applaudissements]
j'aime surtout les ché je vais vous
attrapez petit coquin vous allez voir si
je ne suis pas jouer à colin maillard
ça c'est une bonne force de ses
bienfaits ils n'avaient qu'à ne pas
tricher mais cherchait pas petite soeur
la nuit petit frère dort bien je vais
vous attraper ça y est victoire je
retiens rap petit drôle
soit nicolas je gagnais theekoye de
north ou patrons excuses devant ce n'est
rien et 12 des petits as mis ton fait
une bonne farce que tu méritais sevrin
je la mérite
allons en route
bonne nuit des enfants enfin mes amis
dans un reportage aux coupeurs de feu
leur nounours nicolas et pimprenelle
attendent je veux patron je veux mon le
cheval europe propos mme popova aux
joyeux nounours ça nous fait plaisir de
l'entendre chanter n'est ce pas les
enfants bonsoir pas pro lgv elle
bonsoir nikolov joueuses battre ce soit
au nom quelle ville a dit et allons
prenez-vous la main nous allons faire
une auront là
dans un bocage ouvert de voyages d'y
fleurir à audi veut des clés c'est le
job n'est pas ici l'amour extrême mal à
voile 6
voilà
très bien les [ __ ] mais à présent
parfois avant d'aller se coucher
d'accord
dans un bocage ouvert de feuillage qui
fleurira hobby le décret est celle que
j'aime mais pas ici l'amour extrême wow
la voici
d'infos beauvau où sont ils passés ils
sont trop mignons
bonsoir bonsoir mes petits
j'aime tellement les rondes nous en
ferons encore ses premiers 90 kg sa mort
j'éteins la lumière bonne ni pape
rappelle la coquine elle dort déjà
[Musique]
c'est entendu les enfants nous ferons
encore de belles rondes tombeau cageots
couvert de folle de rage le ne fait pas
tant de bruit le nours des enfants
dorment déjà j'aime tellement les rondes
au trou
bonne nuit fais tu pour marc desenfans
bros 3 bien son nom mais qui est il le
nours mon les chats les salles étaient
pleines de pouces d'un et bien la wla
excellente idée jetée sans la lave et
rendez moi un petit service pack rond
dès que je serai en bas vous me lancerai
attendaient une hausse
merci le bon papa je peux la lancée ça
y'est patron allez-y et voilà merci à
tout de suite
pascal beaufreton échelle allez encore
cassé ne la touchez pas elle est sale
je vais là la vue mafia avec celle des
pins oui à la salle de bain chic alors
on va laver l'échelle fallait une brasse
et de la poudre de savants métaux michel
nouaille lavabo dans le lavabo dont le
lavabo voudrais bien savoir où avec un
désordre par l eau
vous voyez que c'est comme ça qu'on fait
de l'or
ma parole serait navrant je suis déçu
parole de l'osce une salle tabac dans un
tel désordre mais on envoie tout volé tu
peux mettre ton échelle je te fais
collado des enfants qui ont de l'arbre
ont ils ont fini de jouer ils rangent
leur joie oui un peu de savon faux pas
de mettre en colère non je ne me mets
pas en colère trop l'air je suis en
colère au preneur docteur tran j'étais
petit j'avais de l'ordre moi j'en ai
toujours au palais jauron jet tours
tout est ma soeur ennemie la quelle
petite fille ordonné cette allait nous
voir notre maman le nook rodez jamais
vous entendez ce que je vous dis fais
pas de bruit nicollin je crois que nous
nous c'est vraiment colère au lieu d'un
prenait tort bien alors vous m'avez
entendu vous ne laisserait plus de
défendre c'est promis promis juré
nounours bon alors bonne nuit les petits
la jette un la lumière en une manche
bonne niche hermanos fête pour petits
diables
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu peux monter une ourse
ton échelle est bien attaché me revoilà
patronne allons en route
bonnut des enfants
suivez bien les conseils de nounours
de l'ordre toujours de l'ordre soyez
tranquilles ils ont bien compris et moi
je ne suis plus en colère je suis
content car mon échelle et propre dans
millenium bat nuit les petits faites de
beaux rêves de voir des enfants
bonsoir bonsoir
orhan nounours je vois que tu as envie
de danser ce soir bois pas trop j'ai
toujours envie de danser
geoffrey un excellent professeur de
danse si je voulais mais mais oui
pourquoi pas je suis professeur de danse
mon échelle pire pour un pape à propos
pour boom boom pow pow pas content
bonsoir les enfants voulez-vous être
mais c'est là qu'est ce que tu vas nous
apprend
je suis un professeur de danse à votre
lave est prêt et moi je suis professeur
je suis prête attention en place pour le
quadrille roulement attention mesdames
attention messieurs nous allons danser
un quadrillage deux à damas prône l de
secours des sites
quand je dis les clips on s'incline de
roi quand je faire éclater se relèvera
attention surtout ne nous trompons pas
voyons comment nous un peu écouté tous
les deux mois la jolie qui vous salue et
maintenant qu actes nous relevons marche
lentement en comptant les part à deux
rencontres où justin planifiait nous
nous inclinons un peu tous les deux
lolo
mais la machine à aces à lui cracher
merci mademoiselle et pas de quoi dessus
enfin une dernière révérence anti voile
un autre cadre est votre cas et voici
pour notre professeur t'aime tellement
les fleurs merci me petit
si tous les élèves étaient aussi gentil
que vous
il y en aurait trop de professeurs et
pour faire plaisir à notre professeur
nous allons les bonnes nuits mes petits
élèves à demain j'éteins la lumière
fait pour
[Musique]
j'espère que vous faites comme les
élèves de nounours mes petits amis
et que vous allez au lit sans vous faire
prier au patron de charbon de soi rue
quel enfant robichaud est bien en route
professeur nounours bonne nuit les
enfants fêtes de bourg heures bonsoir
mes petits amis peau soit
patron mais bien sûr mon gros nounours
descend vite leur montrer ton beau livre
moi je le raconterai la suite des
aventures de notre petite amie
cornichons ou le joueur cornichons se
trouvent toujours chez le gros bûcheron
qui est très gentil avec lui quand
nichons lui s'occupe de juliette à le
hibou mais juliette a n'est pas toujours
très sage je peux continuer de raconter
mon histoire nounours à l'egypte pas
trop nous sommes preuve l'accord le gros
bûcherons et le petits cornichons sont
en train de charger dans une grande
charrette le bois qu'ils ont coupé et
ramasser pour aller le vendre au village
neuf
il n'arrête pas de travailler quand
michaud il est très courageux mais tout
à coup ils entendent des cris perçants
décrit de lapin pourquoi ils crient
soufflent au oui
cette coquine de julietta pour s'amuser
est en train d'essayer d'attraper un
mignon petit lapin la vienne pourquoi
faut bien que ça me colle à l' on
retourne à la maison juliette a tué
méchante lui dit cornichons juliette à
s'en va et le joli petit lapin qui n'a
plus peur continue de creuser son
terrier qu'est ce que c'est interview un
trou dans la terre dans lequel les
lapins installent leurs bureaux il
gratte avec ses deux pattes et il fait
rouler des cailloux sur les pieds de
cornichons
il gratte une gratte du jour où nous
serons regarde corniche on ramasse
plusieurs cailloux qui sont très beaux
mais ce sont des agates et celle ci est
encore plus belle
c'est une améthyste et notre bûcheron
lui montre une pierre
la plus belle que cornichons et jamais
vu elle est de la couleur des yeux de
maman et cornichons suivi par son ami
retourne dans la cabane maman hélène
bonne dynamique dit ce témoin j'ai une
bio magath
le petit garçon mais les agat dans sa
bouteille avec les perdre les
coquillages la pièce en or et la pierre
de lune aux couleurs changeantes qu'il
garde pour sa maman
faudrait quand même qu'il la retrouve sa
maman tient lui dit le bûcheron et il
laisse tomber l'améthyste précieuse dans
la bouteille
tu la retrouvera ta maman je te le
promets qui quand est-ce qu'ils la
retrouvent new york
la prochaine fois les enfants vous
verrez allons les enfants l'histoire est
finie
nous allons nous coucher tout de suite
le neuf ce qu'ils sont gentils nous ça
bouchonne bonnes et nos noces sony bonne
nuit les petits rats
j'éteins la lumière at home
[Applaudissements]
alors les enfants
l'histoire vous a plu oui eh bien allez
vite vous coucher on n'y va pas trop en
route mon cher nounours bah de nuit fait
pour
[Applaudissements]
voir les enfants
bonsoir bl ce soir nous allons faire de
grandes choses ou les choses bon j'ai
bien peur que nounours est apporté son
livre de cuisine douche froide ma petite
pape rebelles qu'est ce que tu as pas à
livres d'histoire non mon livre de
recettes de cuisine non non c'est nous
qui faisons de la cuisine ce soir elle
nous n'avons pas besoin de tes fameuse
recette bien voir nicolas nicolas
mais non ses mains ce contrat seront
bons
je suis un petit garçon de bonne figure
qui eux mobio le bonbon et les
confitures g20 ont foulé mandat mais je
saurai quelle est logique
la bonaventure ont pu l'amener
aventureux
c'est de la confiture ou ne touchent pas
nous allons assieds toi et regarde on le
bon fromage qui n'a fait son ménage
voilà du bon fromage au lait de celui
qu'il a fait c'est qu'il a fait là
dessous el haj ahmed collatéraux fromage
salade de l'herbe ou ce fromage ne
touchent pas gros gourmand juif où ça ne
fait rien gd pas m'étendre déranger des
blanches jeu font 4 a pour atout
mademoiselle retour voilà de subban moi
seul mot qu enfin voilà de pain
montanari tan tan tan arrêtant pas dans
la sauce pop à narita
enfin marie
mais pas devin il veut pas aller trop du
loup mais c'était pour rémanence ne
plante pas regarde tout ça c'est pour
toi
ainsi font font font les petites
marionnettes massivement font entretenir
et puis s'en vont ainsi font font font
les petites marionnettes à six enfants
sans famille tour et puis s'en vont alan
doss les gothard ce que vous m'avez
gâter les enfants remercient de nuit les
petits faites de beaux rêves
[Musique]
bonne nuit les enfants à voici notre
nounours tu es bien chargé patron regard
du regard du tout ça c'est pour nous on
s'en va j'ai une de ses fins en route
bonne nuit
et merci
merci paul de cadres moi je crois qu'ils
sont perdus
alors qu'est-ce que ça c'est mal mais
zulte apprenait que l'appareil
bonsoir lui au fond c'est toi maman tu
viens tu es nous arrivons nous voilà
vous attend bonsoir les enfants bonsoir
oui nous avons eu quelques petites zones
notre gouverneur ne marche plus
impossible de le faire tourner il est si
lourd que nous avons de la peine à
avancer
tu ferais bien de le vérifier nounours
je m'en occupe pas trop ma lampe de
poche ou la guitare ça a l'air sérieux
[Musique]
que lourd tiens nounours ton et chaîne
plat merci mon petit pas trop propre
propre propre propre propre au bout a
très vite nounours mais qu'est ce que
t'as parts notre gouvernail et des mois
les enfants ce qui le loue ou feuilles
mais didot s'est on va faire un
gouvernail notre gouverneur sert à
diriger notre nuage comme un bateau et
je lui ai apporté ici pour le réparer
car il ne marche pas bien j'en ai besoin
voyons mais mais mais c'est un nid à
l'aja on va le poser devant la fenêtre
sur une chaise pour que les parts on le
retrouve et reviennent dans leur nid on
laissera la fenêtre au maire très bonne
idée
je le pose là il est bien
n'y touchez pas surtout allez vous
coucher les enfants
moi je m'occupe du gouverneur tu
viendras nous dire bonsoir relais bien
sûr les petits à vous pas trop attaché
le bien allez-y vous pouvez leur montée
je m'en occupe
sois tranquille le nours elle est
maintenant vient le voilà voilà
bonne nuit les petits ruiné nos la
jetant la lumière
à demain adobe
bonne nuit nicolas fait pour est la
première connue des enfants n'oubliez
pas de faire votre toilette de bien vous
laver les dents
embrassez vos parents et allez vite vous
coucher on y va patron le gouvernail
d'être en place tout est en ordre mon
chien nounours en route allons vite nous
coucher nous aussi 2 adobe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à